[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
really excited to be talking about all
things humanity all things unity all
things retrieving these core values of
ours and bringing them forward into the
future we have dr. Douglas rushkoff
joining us on the show hey thanks for
coming on it I'm super excited this book
is extremely timely right now your voice
and your messaging is extremely timely
right now and I'm excited to unpack this
in a bunch of nuanced for those that
don't know
Douglas his background he's for the last
four years been a professor at City
University of New York and media theory
in digital economics he's authored 20
books and most recently team human
they're all in media tech culture and
also he hosts team human his podcasts as
well and that links in the bio for you
guys to check out and yeah let's jump
into this Douglas I love talking about
things on a big history perspective to
start out we find ourselves over a long
period of evolution as now these social
creatures that are stewards of earth and
now we have to figure out how to how to
work together and prosper moving forward
so what do you think about the current
state of humanity well I think we kind
of lost the plot in some ways you know
if we want to play the big the big
historical picture I think right now we
are misremembering evolution and some
battle for survival of the fittest
individual whereas the real story of
evolution that one at least the one that
Darwin and evolutionary biologists seem
to tell is that of the way that species
collaborate both amongst themselves and
with other species in order to ensure
mutual survival over time you know I was
taught that the trees competed for
sunlight and
the big trees would get higher and then
crowd out the little ones that would
wither in the shade and it turns up it's
the opposite I mean read secret life of
trees a nice little book and we find out
that the big trees are sharing nutrients
with the little trees through a network
of my Celia in the soil which turns out
not to be dirt but alive and then when
the leaves fall off the big trees the
little evergreens then share nutrients
back with the big trees it's like duh
they're using diversity strategies and
sharing strategies and networking with
the mushrooms that are taking a service
fee from the transfer of nutrients it's
like wow this is a big collaborative act
you know and if human beings are the
most advanced species it's really just
to the extent that we've developed the
most advanced ways of collaborating and
coordinating activity so then I look at
everything from language in text to
money and education and technology and
television and the internet all is ways
that our collaborative species have has
developed kind of new platforms and
modalities for collaboration but it
feels like each one of these inventions
also has a counter effect each one of
these inventions also can alienate us
from who we are from our kind of
essential value as people and whether
it's text or TV or radio or the internet
they lead us to see human beings in
terms of our utility value rather than
our core essential sacred dare I say at
value you don't need God I'm not saying
we need to believe in God but that
there's some something special about us
and we kind of lose track of that and
then start doing technology to people
you know we look at language to
manipulate people television to turn us
into consumers or digital technology to
play us as as a medium so humans have
become the medium rather than kind of
the message of the digital landscape and
I'm trying to kind of reify the human
and to say no we deserve a place in this
thing - yes and the two words that I
love that you so frequently our
collaboration and community
Haitian that those are the two and in
competition has had its place in
evolution as well but the two that are
so human to us is this collaboration
communication and you listed these early
language there's the transfer of value
with things like money and all of these
ways that we have found ourselves now
evolved over this last hundred thousand
plus years to see that okay look at we
have buildings and electricity and
airplanes and now the internet all these
great things but what are the core human
values of this empathy this eye contact
this heart centric feeling that you're
another human and that we're not gonna
beat each other over the heads for money
we're not gonna psychometrically profile
each other for the for our ability to
sell each other things that we don't
need so why have we lost our position in
human centric values what has been that
because you you also say this in your
book you say the TV was that one of the
first things that isolated us right and
then now we have the immediate access to
these devices every single time we feel
any sort of social awkwardness so again
another isolation piece so is have these
been that kind of the big driving forces
yeah I mean you can trace it to a whole
lot of different things some people
trace it to agriculture and once you had
agriculture in a plot of land and now
you're kind of you know kind of
disturbing or raping the earth to get
stuff you're planting seed in there to
get your bounty and some some people
blame when we became sedentary when we
stop wandering around once you had homes
and then you were kind of trying to
protect your home that's when the
patriarchy was born you had the women
and children inside and the real world
outside and you did whatever you did to
your family in there and started to
being more concerned about the the
preservation of your kin and lineage
over the group cohesion I mean today it
feels like we've forgotten that being
human that's what I call it being human
as a team sport yes yeah and that that I
mean that on on I mean there's so many
ways to argue it I could argue it on it
get in
great New Age soul level but we could
argue it on a biological level to that
the human organism is not an individual
human the human organism is a group of
humans it's like you don't see a
bacteria alone right there in that
colony right you don't see a club fungi
what's a mushroom which mushroom is a
club of fungus all working together
humans are like that humans are more
like a termite mind 9 9 or termite mound
than we are just dude in place you know
dude in a solo apartment somewhere you
know by himself that's but this is that
guy a hypothesis yeah I'm super exciting
yeah I mean Gaia hypothesis goes further
and says the whole planet is one being
you know and there's this kind of
consciousness it's really what what you
know those of us in the early hippie
dippie days of the late eighties early
nineties internet you know there was a
psychedelic revival there was a rave
revival there were Spanish cero playings
there was fractals there was chaos math
and there was the internet and all these
things sort of told us the same thing
that we were gonna wire up the you know
the human beings would be the nervous
system of Gaia and we'd bring the planet
into consciousness and all and it was a
it was a sweet idea and however naive it
was it was certainly a more pro-social
pro-human vision than i'm gonna make a
billion dollars by creating algorithms
that manipulate other people into being
addicted to my platform that's a much
darker vision and the people who have
that vision and I've met a lot of them
the tech billionaires who've made the
billions off this they're really afraid
of what they've done they're the people
who are the most powerless they're the
ones who really believe that humanity's
about to go off a cliff they were
investing hundreds of millions of
dollars in in shelters and and doomsday
bunkers they asked me regularly where
should I put my bunker how do I maintain
control of my security force after the
apocalypse what will I do after money so
these
the folks oddly enough because they see
the future as something to bet on rather
than something to create because they're
part of the speculative economy rather
than the creative take real genuinely
creative technology a community they are
they feel at a loss they don't they hire
scenario planners and futurist to tell
them what's gonna happen so they can
place their bets
so realities are roulette wheel to them
and that's a really scary place to be so
I realized it that and it's kind of
funny I mean the Bible talks about it
that Pharaoh's heart got hardened after
he took all the money that these people
lose their creative capacity they lose
their empathic capacity and they're not
the people to whom we should be turning
for answers yeah you again you took
another big history perspective you
brought us all the way back to
agriculture you brought us back to to
having our first sort of rooted homes
and what that did for our social culture
and so then when we take a big history
perspective and we look at all these
instances over the last even several
thousand years where we became triggers
of eight of towards a social behavior
right that that has slowly got us to
partially where we're at also a big part
of this is this exponential population a
hockey stick right we've seen because
now it's becoming more more easy to to
just be like oh there's there's there's
four billion PDS I'd the circle in Asia
and then there's more there than there
are outside of that and we can just
profile them based on what their likes
are on the social platforms and then we
can advertise to them and we can make
money the shareholders make money and
they and then that sort of this that
that's sort of capitalistic extraction
rather than a figuring out how to make a
cooperative gain is something that needs
to be relooked at as business plans of
today in today's future of capitalism
2.0 what it what does that look like for
an inclusive economy that maximizes the
potential of all people I think all we
have to do is look back at a herd of the
late Middle Ages right before capitalism
was invented you know or what we think
of capitalism now and we you know the
Crusades had just ended the men had
opened up all these trade routes to the
Ottomans you know to the Moors and they
brought back all these weird innovations
with them like the bazaar which we
called the market local currencies and
market monies which work like poker
chips that were invented in the morning
and then they would be expired by the
end of the day it was so they had an
economy that they built a local city
based economy that was optimized for the
velocity of transactions rather than the
extraction of value and people got
wealthy we got the middle class they've
called the the burgers became the
bourgeois and all of a sudden the former
peasants of feudalism were now
craftspeople and trading and doing well
and the problem with that of course was
that as the people got wealthy the
wealthy got relatively poorer and they
got afraid they hadn't worked those
families of the feudal lords hadn't
worked in ten centuries they hadn't
created value what are we gonna do
so they made trade illegal and business
illegal it's really what they did that's
what capitalism was they invented the
chartered monopoly which said through
law that one company would have a
monopoly and shoes one whatever monopoly
in the East India from whatever monopoly
in cotton and that was the King's friend
and now if you worked as a shoemaker you
had to now go work for his majesty's
royal shoe company as an employee
selling your time like labour the only
people who did that before were slaves
the second thing they did was invented
central currency all the local monies
were illegal now you had a borrow money
at interest from the central Treasury
once you're borrowing money at interest
it means the economy has to grow so that
more interest can be paid to the person
who lent out the money how do you grow
the economy colonialism we went and we
took over all these different parts of
the world but now we've ran out of
places to take over but we still have
that operating system so these kids
sweet kids 18 19 years old Mark
Zuckerberg whoever they come up with a
tech idea they drop out of college to go
do it before they take in economics
before they take an anthropology or
sociology psychology or develop
spiritually right or develop the
preferred
the prefrontal cortex they don't even
have myelin sheaths on their on their
prefrontal cortex yet they're their
babies they're impulsive and they listen
to these Silicon Valley entrepreneurs
and investors who tell them now you're
gonna pivot your company from a social
company to a data mining company and
they build their technologies on top of
an operating system called corporate
capitalism if they don't even understand
and so they think they're being
disruptive but they're actually
reactionary they are defending the
powers-that-be they're defending the
operating system they're not unearthing
it you point to this creativity from the
past that's so cool that the things like
the Silk Road how they enable people to
go and see what what Indonesia could
bring to Europe and what Africa could
bring to way to other parts of the world
and and that is so that is what the
potential is for today's internet like
you saw it could unleash this full
imagine of potential of people and yet
we haven't gotten to that iteration of
it quite yet and then also we are
speaking a bit about these people of a
greater wealth let's say and that when
you look at these several thousand
billionaires on the planet there are
interesting things happening like The
Giving Pledge and then that there is
some sort of an allocation of some of
the Fed once they realize they've taken
too much money out of the system they
try to kind of jam it back in there you
know but it's like dude you took too
much to begin with you know if you're
gonna give back 99% of your billions
think about what if you hadn't created a
rapacious evil company what if you would
stop when you just had a couple of
billion you know you weren't allowed to
because you took too much money and you
had too high evaluation then you had to
give a thousand mixed returns a Sequoia
Capital or whoever it was but imagine if
you would stay true to your original
vision Facebook Google all of them said
we're gonna be better platforms than
Yahoo and everybody else because we're
not going to use advertising and then
they went and did it but they're all
that I mean the economic answer so I
wrote about throwing rocks the Google
bus in the last book the economic answer
is distributism or where trevor is
calling platform cooperatives all you
need is to
own the means of production then you
reap the reward so what if the uber
drivers owned uber then even if they're
doing R&D for their own robot
replacements at least they own the
company after that no or looking at how
can we have people earn money I know
this is so old-fashioned but earn money
by buying or pipe by selling goods and
services rather than selling stock so
you have a company where the chief
purpose of the company is to sell
something at a profit it's like this old
way but it they call it bootstrapping
now because they can't even imagine what
that means as if it's artificial but the
idea is that you make a profit on what
you've sold and you take that money and
you reinvest it in the company and you
scale up that way rather than getting a
whole bunch of money from some investors
and then really twisting the arm of
municipalities and government to change
laws so that you get to grow
exponentially for some short time so you
could sell your shares and get out of
town we're identifying some of the
interesting potentials for solving
what's what's going on in this anti
human agenda we're and on the team human
agenda things like you were just listing
are quite exciting and let's let's save
some of the cool solutions because we
got a lot of cool solutions let's stick
for a little bit longer with what we see
with data data seems to be what is the
big the oil of today yeah and the the
potential for data to be doing great
things like these solutions of oh we see
that you're watching a guitar video on
YouTube and by the way Douglas who's a
couple blocks away from you please
guitar would you like to go meet up with
him in person I do I making these these
the the algorithms can be made for human
values but in many ways they're anti
humans so let's talk a bit about those
the algorithms the supercomputers being
trained on these billions of human
animals and then what the business plans
themselves they're tied to the attention
economy the limitation in human
attention a hundred twenty billion hours
of human attention per day on the planet
and let's synthesize that and then
move on as well to the solutions well
I'm in a problem with the way we're
using you know AI and algorithms now is
I mean you go on Facebook and the basic
business plan now is to use your past
behavior as interpreted through data to
put you in a statistical bucket and then
do whatever they have to to get you to
behave true to your statistical bucket
because they really only are able to
predict with about 80 percent accuracy
it's the kind of the Pareto principle
with 80% accuracy if you're gonna you
know realize you're gay or go on a diet
or get divorced or do whatever it is
you're gonna do so they know with 80%
accuracy that you're gonna go on a diet
in the next three months they're gonna
start filling your newsfeed with you're
looking fat or look what happens to the
heart of someone that eats the wrong
kind of food and all and that's not just
to sell the products of the particular
advertiser it's to get you to behave
truer to your statistical profile they
want to get that 80% up to 85 or 90 or
95 percent but what are they doing in
the process they're taking the 20% of
weird human behavior of anomalous
interesting creative stuff and trying to
reduce it so why at a moment when we
need novel solutions to really
intractable problems would we want to
increase automatic human behavior would
we want to decrease novel solutions to
things you know it's because it's it's
increases the accuracy of prediction and
the accuracy of prediction is not how we
win this thing a interesting
counterpoint could be potentially seeing
a class-four Skillshare that you were
80% interested in taking or potentially
a and and you pursuing wanting to do
something else creative and being
advertised that and having a little bit
of a push a little more fire under your
butt could be but you know the other
hand it's still the whole energy of it
is technology acting on people rather
than people acting through technology so
oh we're gonna nudge people when they
should get off the computer we're gonna
nudge people when they should kiss their
loved one so oh all these you know the
machines of loving grace whatever
they're all gonna encourage us to be
better you know it's it it's it's the
same as the kind of the humane
technology movement and there's sweet
people I'm a mean totally well but I
feel like there's a dynamic problem with
it that that it's like let's treat
humans humanely like like cage free
chickens you know we're gonna be nice to
them on the way to the slaughter so the
technology yes technology you're gonna
have to take people's data you're gonna
have to take their money and time and
attention but try to do it a little bit
more humane sure and it's like no no no
I don't want technology treating me
human I don't want technology treating
me at all I want to be treating the
technology you know and so it's a
there's a there's a almost an energy
problem there there's a it's the wrong
framing of it where human beings are
still the object rather than the subject
we are the ground rather than the figure
and that's what I'm trying to really
change to try to elicit an immune
response from humans so they kind of
stand up and you know oh no I'm I'm me
I'm what I am the other funny thing
about data and I do know that there's
some terrific things that we could do if
we developed a data Commons that
scientists could use to try to cure
cancer and figure out different things
and looking it would be a brilliant
thing but the data economy that's a
bubble if ever there was one because the
data economy is just really an extension
of marketing and advertising marketing
and advertising is never ever ever ever
made up more than 4% of GDP because you
need 96% of stuff to sell to then do all
that advertising and market research for
so now if we have a multi trillion
dollar industry then the whole Nasdaq
stock exchange is depending on the value
of data
everybody's exit strategy is I'm gonna
sell the data then we're in a data
bubble the data's are the new tulips
yeah okay well one of one of the things
that I think's important to point out is
the the
opening up data silos and doing things
like making data Commons can potentially
solve a lot of the problems that we have
with preventative medicine which is very
exciting but to have something saying
like oh you should go and you know kiss
your spouse today because you haven't
kissed your stuff's while it's kind of
like I should evolve spiritually more to
be able to understand that I should be a
better spouse and I should work on
myself more alright and yeah it's kind
of like since your self work rather than
like mmm these technological nudges that
that we evolved from Kindergarten
regimens prior to unleashing artificial
general I mean my wife gets these now
because she's on Facebook to get these
birthday greetings from people and she
doesn't have a real birthday on there
but she gets them when she said her
birthday was and it's like this
automatic thing and it's kind of funny
so here all these people that don't
really know her birthday yes right and
they're just obviously doing this thing
because Facebook told them to and it it
kind of I don't know it kind of debases
the whole thing that's a very
dehumanizing thing is setting a birthday
on a bond a platform that's not actually
a birthday and then seeing these people
that are because I remember like an old
TV shows it was always like a like the
executive at work like his secretary
would tell him today's your wife birth
what birthday and let me go oké okay
will you go out to May season buy her
something pick something nice out for
her here's $40 and it you look down on
that guy right and now we use technology
for the same exact purpose you know what
should I get her wish list and they put
just enough know it you know and then
you can get a good pot to put just
enough noise in it so it's not exactly
what she wants so she know the computer
didn't do it so and then maybe she will
think you did it cuz it's a little bit
off it's close to her taste but not
quite well when you
you only need more than 300 likes in
order to in order for an artificial
intelligence to understand you better
than your wife understands you then
that's again then are we're literally
training algorithms to understand
ourselves better than even our
significant others do right or to
understand certain things about
ourselves things yeah yeah because the
in order to actually be able to look at
someone in the eyes and deeply see all
of the nuance of the facial expression
and emotion and all that is that's a
very human thing this is one of those
central human values it's okay so we
talked a bit about the data and we
talked a bit about about the psycho
metrics and the deep fakes are a whole
nother crazy thing in the way they're
gonna geopolitically affects
civilization but we're now we're into
human we talked a lot about taking the
values that we find most human centric
and embedding them into the technology
of the future and so give us some of
your best takeaways from being able to
embed those human values in the future I
mean it's just what do we want I mean
it's it's kind of almost too easy that
it's laughable so it's like okay now
we're programming Facebook to help us
see other people as adversaries because
they make more money if we're polarized
so what if we programmed Facebook to
help us see adversaries as humans as
other people that's kind of crazy what
if you know instead of creating platform
monopolies that that use scorched-earth
tactics to take over industries not even
to make the industry's better but just
to have monopolies to leverage then into
another vertical what if we organized
our new companies as platform
cooperatives where the workers who are
working own the means of production
you don't need socialism you don't have
to redistribute the spoils of capitalism
after the fact you pre distribute that
means a production before the fact I
mean they're just it's you could make
almost any
at or platform it sounds so primitive
but if you do it to help people
accomplish something they want to
accomplish rather than to deliver some
aspect of that person to some sponsor
yeah okay that this is actually really
interesting it's almost yeah rather than
thinking about it from a perspective of
of uh of a shareholders first in a
shareholders only mentality there's also
and there's employees that help make
this product or service there's the
people that are using it and then the
this despoil is coming like you said
from a grassroots sort of a cooperative
a perspective of things like you know
Ace Hardware rainbow grocery Wikipedia
Mozilla there's these really good
examples of organizations that have sort
of a deeper more deeper ethos to them
than necessarily the ones that are just
exploiting extract well right well they
have a human value and again now these
are called soft you know they have some
soft human value like knowledge or
humanities or art or love or unity or
respect these are soft there's no
utilitarian immediate utilitarian metric
to associate with them so as far as
digital technology is concerned they
don't exist you know capitalism exists
in the digital realm that you can
measure it it's numbers you know what
about land
what about labor you know they don't
really figure into digital capitalism
because they don't they can't grow
exponentially they don't land is fixed
land doesn't scale humans don't scale
the only thing that scales is money yeah
that was a very interesting point about
about business plans you come with the
business plan and then it's how do you
get rid of as many humans as possible in
the business plan so that you can scale
right what's effectively cuz humans want
healthcare right if you have one
employees I know but whenever you pitch
something they're like oh but you need
grad students to actually analyze that
data screw that it'll never scale you're
gonna need one person for every thousand
customers
that's not that's not gonna work you
know you need one cut one person for
every million customers maybe you know
then we could we could we can see it
working I have an interesting thought
for you let's explore this because
there's this there's this idea that
moonshot thinking is extremely important
that you want people to think that they
can change the world in very interesting
ways and and help guide us to more
towards prosperity on the other side of
things we don't necessarily always need
to have a I want to impact seven point
seven billion people mentality
sometimes impacting one person in just a
communication that you have that day is
extremely important with the butterfly
effect and casting a positive weight on
the world afterward after that single
interaction so how do you kind of
balance those things out human beings
don't operate at scale you just don't I
mean you can have some organizations
that do but you know when we look at the
climate change problem say you know
we've got a president who doesn't
believe in air doesn't care about it
whatever it is it's not is the nation
state the best way to enact climate
change solutions Wars the city-state I
mean you look go back to that moment in
the Renaissance I was talking about
where where the we got central
currencies and we got the the Charter
monopoly and the corporation it's also
when we shifted from the city-state
which is sort of an organic amalgamation
of people the termite mound of humans to
the nation-state which is a totally
abstract artificial boundary that is a
myth of origin and nationalism and it's
a caca right it's not real so the the
the the city-state and and people
collaborating together in that way
actually you you can you can there are
emergent solutions that may not be
appropriate everywhere else you know
just last night I was an Institute for
the future doing this talk and they were
saying yeah but how are we gonna figure
out a solution for this whole thing and
how are you gonna get it to everybody
and it's like well what if the solution
for climate change was actually
thousands of diverse and different
solutions what if the solutions for
climate change was as diverse as
planetary life itself yes so the coral
reef has one solution for climate change
and the planes have another and the city
people have a different one yep and
that's what needs to in order for that
to happen we need to unleash the full
creative potential of all these
different cultures and right well rather
than intentionally stymie human beings
creative capacity which is what we're
doing now because the more creative
people are the more unpredictable they
are and the harder it is to bet on the
future
okay there's there's another pressing
field that I think should be explored as
what we're talking about okay so we are
now entering the exponential technology
hockey stick and it's permeating into
every single aspect of our culture and
children are not necessarily being
properly educated to be you know
spiritual heart centric unity oriented
people by parents and communities we
don't really have the necessary social
fabric in order to do so yet and so what
would be some of these main tips or
principles that we could endow children
with well I mean we've turned education
from a celebration of human dignity into
an extension of the workplace you know
education was invented so that public
education was for the the coal miner you
know so that after a day of working in
the and this is that exponential
technology that is talking about and
this is a big aspect of the distractive
economy in many aspects yeah but I don't
even know the artist who made this if
this is the nightmare or the or the the
dream you know they could be the Utopia
in Subway's yeah but but education went
from being a a compensation for work to
an extension of work you know it's to
increase a child's utility value it's
it's the principals of the schools go to
the CEOs to find out what skills do you
want so it becomes a way for the the
corporation to externalize job training
rather than a way to to
a gift to young people so they can grow
up informed and inquisitive and and and
creative and that's an easy flip all we
have to do say look let's get the iPads
out of there let's stop worrying about
all this Common Core and whatever and
let's have the kids be in a room
together just a little bit even if we
take you know 15 minutes a week we're
gonna let the kids just be with their
teacher and each other because now I've
been teaching what five years at CUNY
every year I get more notes from
students on the first day of class
saying I've been excused by my doctor
from having to do in-class presentations
or class participation because they have
so much social anxiety that they you
know I'll learn I'm here but don't
expect me to do anything and I feel bad
for them you know cuz I understand it's
a disability and I believe the note but
it's because they I would argue that the
the increase in this anxiety is going up
because they're not getting older yeah
yeah that's the the theory of the
coddling of the American mind is that
were slowly not building up our immune
system enough to these things like if we
did a little bit of peanut powder a
little tiny men and built ourselves up
we wouldn't have so many of the peanut
allergies if we did a little bit of
public speaking exposure a little bit of
group work exposure we would face our
fears and get better and better instead
of just this binary close off to all of
it that's making things worse and worse
right we barely talk to our neighbors
you know the kids don't talk with their
family I mean the interesting thing is
when you talk to families about you know
technology use it's the kids who
complain that the parents are on the
smart phones not the parents playing
about the kids kids give up on their
parents invention the glass if you care
more about your phone than me then I'll
go look at my phone too
Amelia you you gave this point that I
want to I want to know then for a
solution there's there's multiple
aspects there's this kind of like
top-down sort of restructuring of the
ethical mindsets of the technologists
and entrepreneurs that are many of the
billionaires and whatnot in them and
then realizing we need a human
we need to somehow enable the creative
potential and then there's the bottom up
action of figuring out how to best do
things like like focus on on what makes
us most human and and embed that more
into the skills that we teach kids and
then grow from that end and then they
kind of meet potentially as a yeah I'm
sure but even if the top-down ones don't
do the top-down when we can still do the
bottom-up one yeah you know and the
bottom-up one's easy that's just spend
some time with other people now I'll
even tell kids you know young people
it's like start with 10 minutes a week
where you just with another person and
it's unbearable I know but get rid of
all the tech and you're not gonna and
just be with somebody so you know maybe
have sex even with them you can't be
shooting it at the same time you know it
couldn't be producing all of it
professionally right yeah you know it's
amateur right but yeah just put
everything away and just be play cards
if you have to you know but you start
that reorient yourself or reacquaint
yourself and then you're also you have
so much more resistance to the mimetic
EBG bees you know yeah
yes so then and yeah the another good
thing for bottom-up just like you said
potentially if you do have someone or
something that seems a little foreign to
you maybe their ideology or their
perspective or where they came from or
whatever take that first step towards
that that here that's where all of the
treasure lies on the other side of the
field does that's what I said Tony on
the back of the book what do you find
the others right find the others and
find the others means you know find the
other people like you who will get who
are on Team human and all that but
ultimately it means finally others the
other you know if you're a nice blue
state you know San Francisco progressive
then go find some red state Trump person
and finally human being there find the
fear that's underlined why do they want
the wall why are they scared of the
Mexicans what is it that they believe
where is that more essential fear coming
from and you'll find the human there
that's huge that that's that's huge that
that's it because the human is what is
what binds us together what unites us
with that with Gaia with the plants and
the animals and the earth energy well
you start with the humans and the real
others are gonna be the plants and the
dogs and the all the species we're
killing
we're killing like a couple species a
day right I mean I know my daughter I'm
by the time she grows up there's not
gonna be saltwater fish yeah I I really
hope we can solve some of the dilemmas
in the oceans where we in our in our
common data bank in our data Commons the
their the I don't think it should take
us having to discover a life outside of
Earth to realize we're all one tribe it
shouldn't be that far and it's de
invasion but we're at the place now
where people really don't know what the
difference between humans and zombies is
yeah lewbert we're stuck there and that
some fear it's a fear see I grew up
before you so I had this guy mr. Rogers
on TV loved mr. Rogers and mr. Rogers
used to say you're special just the way
you are and I like you and all that
comes and and the idea I was grew up
with the idea that human beings are
special just the way we are that we came
in with a kind of integrity and
everything did every tree everything I
mean you're gonna step on some bugs now
and again you know but every every thing
is part of this you know if you can get
there is what we're doing then a little
bit of this spiritual remembering is
what we're doing we're remembering our
humanity because a lot of the cultural
programming can strip it away yeah and a
lot of our are utilitarian a particular
scientific utilitarian model doesn't see
it you know it's funny I see this as an
extremely positive boat because I'm
saying we can rally together we can do
this and all that and you're identifying
some of the malevolence as well yeah
some but half the reviewers think it's a
hopeless and negative book and I think
it's because they don't when I say oh
look we can establish rapport we can be
together this is a new conspiracy it's
just like it's just it's just going by
and they don't even see that as tangible
that's just like happy we're happy words
and they don't see that as a wait a
minute he I'm actually talking about
reifying you know that if I say
something like you know on planet earth
human beings have the home-field
advantage yeah which we do you know I
think that just it just flies by it all
they see is what's happening to my stock
what's happening to to this company and
and the algorithms doing bad things to
our children think so they get kind of
stuck to the yellow sand there's gotta
be more to this human experiment past
the utility of making money off of each
other and I think that's why it goes
some over certain people's heads because
again they're just it's a it's a it's a
myopic view of specifically wrenched
stockholders and and [ __ ] and and what's
in it for me what's in it for me what
how do I apply this to my company how's
the quarter and then on the other hand
these things that we're listing they
actually have some of these most deeply
embedded human centric principles doing
the deep eye contact the deep love the
finding people that are that may not
have the same values and ideas as you do
a different place of origin and just
going and asking them questions talking
to them these
these ways of developing ourselves out
socially and emotionally will bring team
human together and and not separate us I
wanna I want to want to ask you about
this there's a big push and and I'm one
I'm gonna play on the side of the push I
think okay the push of transhumanism
okay because I've spoken about the
several times now the transhumanism push
in many ways is very interesting we are
doing things like enabling us to live a
little bit longer so we can be more
creative longer hopefully you know doing
things like that that eventually maybe
we can do things like become digital
beings instead of biological beings that
artificial intelligence can eradicate
some suffering and whatnot it's just
that we want to ethically be developed
prior to this this transhumanist push to
this artificial general intelligence
that way we can most effectively embed
these human centric principles in these
in these technologies of our future
would you say that's a decent way I mean
most transhumanist just want to get away
from being human it's a Gnostic urge
they hate who they are
they hate the flesh they hate reality
they're scared of women they're wet
inside and it's a whole you know and
they want to go back up up get out get
out into that thing you know and there's
so much about being alive that we don't
yet know that to think we're even
anywhere close to uploading
consciousness to a chip or to creating a
self-aware robot or you know doing any
or building an AI that actually does
anything is um such hubris it's so nuts
you know I get it I know where it came
from the Soviets came over back in the
fact they went to Esalen and met with
our New Age people in the 1980s
the two-track diplomacy program and
their Russian cosmesis were the first
people to talk about building these
robots and this is future of human
consciousness and all and when that mix
for Silicon Valley LSD and the hot tubs
of Esalen we got these crazy singularity
people bless their little hearts bless
their little hearts but human beings are
too weird that human beings have the
ability to embrace ambiguity to sustain
not knowing human beings have the
ability to watch a David Lynch movie not
understand a thing that happened but
still get immense pleasure
whoahhh paradox those are so right and
when a human being experiences all it
actually increases their immune system
and does all this stuff it's part of
being human it's part of being healthy
but we don't really fully understand
what it is and we don't have to
understand what it is and even if we
understand that then there'll be some
other part that we know so my problem
with uploading humans to something else
is it's gonna be like the CDs they told
us that CDs are gonna be better than
records better than records and now we
know they're not that CDs have a
sampling rate it turns everything into
kind of a sawtooth wave it's kind of
cold
you could try to warm it up with vacuum
tubes afterwards but a record and analog
still has something else in continuous
sound that the digital doesn't do you
want to find that out after you've
uploaded yourself oh it turned I'm not
really conscious here am i no oops we
don't even understand a square
centimeter of soil how are we gonna
understand you know or square centimeter
of the actual brain tissue right yeah
yeah it's squares and we were swale or
the ocean right only computer scientists
say they know what consciousness is
none of the neuroscientists or spiritual
leaders yeah yes so there's a processing
process of maturity that needs to
develop first maturing of our ethics and
our morals and our if the we're goal was
actually to get out what's not even to
get
it's just a degrees-of-freedom just
making it an option is to explore that
that realm because so it's exciting to
think about what it would be like to
design worlds yes this one is gorgeous
and beautiful in every single way
possible but I kind of just like wanna
maybe for an hour a day just like jump
into a simulated reality where I can
plan it hop to different areas of the
exhibit life but better
did you like Second Life yeah yeah it's
no it's okay just drop acid or drop DMT
and you'll go to that other place like
there's nobody else there there's nobody
there there's like these weird things
yeah that's right how do you actually
get a socially bond you know will you
actually feel this you know on your on
your haptic on your haptic suit it feels
like that's when I actually place my ear
on your chest and I hear your heartbeat
is that will I actually hear a heartbeat
will it be the same like right day and
I'll tell you stuff happens stuff has
happened in my life that at that was
unexpectedly rich I had a daughter when
she's this little baby like you know
couple months old put your daughter your
new daughter on your chest on your skin
and it's like it's like I mean and I've
had good sex and stuff in my life but
this was a cosmic or DNA resonance I
don't know what the hell that was I'm
sure it was old caveman protect your
child and some intimacy thing but it was
like this oh you know they're these life
experiences that I don't think we're
fully know what they are that are so
yeah you know your little chakras open
and God bless I mean I'll go and visit
Jason Silva out on his you know Second
Life Island or something that'll be fun
you know play the greatest video game of
all time or ready player one yeah
jumping around you get we're
intellectualizing so much and that's
maybe what ends up in many ways
taking us away from this humanizing
heart centric I love your example of
your daughter I love that example it's
like a melting that's something ethereal
there's no real words that can describe
that spiritual sensation and you know
even just last night for me I actually
felt like a social primate uh-huh for a
moment when I was you know leaning up
against someone else's chest and hearing
their heartbeat and really just bonding
a social bonding there's just there's
nothing in the world like it right and
when we spend so much time
intellectualizing about blockchain a I
biotech but the reason we do that is
because along with the other along with
those primal experiences historically
there's also was like saber-toothed
Tigers and stuff you know it was scary
out there and people died of all think
things would just jump on you I was
watching them there they did their
rerelease of 2001 Kubrick and there's
this scene where the kind of monkey
caveman people they're they're sitting
on this cliff at night and you think
they should be sleeping but they're just
listening because there's like some big
creature just growling and they're just
like and I was thinking about how many
nights for how many hundreds of
thousands of years did my ancestors do
that and that baked-in say no wonder a
land must wants to get off the planet no
the billionaires want to hide from the
you know the zombie apocalypse of humans
who are gonna come for revenge after we
find out what they've done to our brains
you know of course they that's it's so
baked in that fear but where we're
building too much to insulate ourselves
from that imagined fear that the
saber-tooth Tigers are not there anymore
it's safe it is safe you know people you
are aid yeah the Mexicans are not coming
to rape you they're not it's really okay
exhale girlfriend yeah yeah and okay I
want to I want to ask you a couple last
questions on the way
all right what would you say is a core
driving principle of your life I'm just
taking it one day at a time right now I
mean it's changed I mean I wanted to try
to originally I don't know save the
world from itself reduce people's level
of fear of Technology and each other so
they could bring their best selves
forward and it's changed now that I'm in
my 50s and I've written 20 books and
made for TV documentaries and had the
platform and all that now it's kind of
different now what I want to do is use
what platform and legacy I have to to
get other voices heard you know that's
why I'm doing a podcast it's really get
other people on this one's on team Hume
and that one's on team human you know
help others I went to teach at City
College not at Princeton you know your
City College and look at you know and
engage with kids or the first generation
and their families to go to college
sometimes first generation to be in
America it's a it's a sanctuary for
dreamers and-and-and and undocumented
people and whatever and really in
franchise is the disenfranchised you
know give them the confidence and and so
what gets me up in the morning is
thinking that you know I can help
restore some dignity to people's lives
yeah it's beautiful and then if you
could rebuild civilization from scratch
how would you design it
I would I would try to build in an
awareness among people that every step
they take every step they take and let's
call it away from their kind of
essential nature's animals comes with
some drawbacks right that you have to
compensate if we move from bugs to
language or language to text or text to
radio each one of these things is great
don't give them up but remember that
you're gonna have to be aware of what
you're doing and compensate for it you
know in order to retrieve and retain the
humanity humanity in this next realm if
you're on Twitter if you're on Facebook
remember all right I'm barking commands
at people we're gonna have to be extra
careful that they don't get insulted or
afraid I love that big history lens on
on how we've evolved again you're you're
hitting it really well there it helps
because you realize you can't go back
it's never about going back it's about
retrieving and bringing forward you know
and that's what you know reviewers in
The Wall Street Journal in these places
whatever they all keep saying I want to
go back in time I don't I'm just saying
you put your right foot forward and then
you got to bring your left foot forward
to and we put our right foot forward in
this last 500 years of corporate
capitalism and it's like we're refusing
to bring the left foot in front of the
right now gotta bring the other foot
then you know we're just trying to do a
split you know that's that's a it's a
very interesting way to put it the
500-year right foot forward of
capitalism helping evolved civilization
and then the spiritual left foot forward
has been lagging behind and it's in its
development things like yeah meditation
art have taken a complete backseat right
and even when we're doing it now I don't
know it's better than nothing but we
have acts that meditate you you know so
and don't worry your brain state's gonna
be better look how much more efficient
you'll be
productivity is gonna go up it's not why
you meditate yeah yeah it's a spiritual
communion with the infinite do it for
its own sake but for its own sake
yeah okay last last to here do you spend
much time thinking about simulation
theory no no I don't think so maybe I do
but I don't think this solution
oh that no simulation don't worry about
it
well it's real enough but just it
renders so quickly doesn't it sometimes
it feels like you know that you are
really fast what because this look it's
a complicated world and purposely so to
get through the adversity that
civilization has to face in order to to
prosper and it's just one of many of
these experiments it's easier to
understand it as a a it's an
interpretation of a unified quantum
field okay
no okay and and collaborative and
collaborative it's a collaborative
creative act yeah you know yes that's
good that's good yeah but it's not some
girl grad student at Berkeley made us
you know in a petri dish or something
until we literally do that in a hundred
years I don't particularly care they've
gone through all this trouble you know
I've looked for the seams how okay last
question what's the most beautiful thing
in the world right now you sorry
you're the other person you're my I mean
it was beautiful thing in the world yeah
is I mean I think it's nature it's a
nature is the is that counter entropic
Drive you know nature is beauty it's the
quest for beauty
and when we can tie ourselves closer
together to that nature that's when we
can tie together as team human on this
lonely pale blue dot in the car when we
can enact it embody it yes you know yes
yes Douglas what a pleasure this is Ben
yeah thank you so much you do just
scratching the surface together this
look in your mission you to you to
everyone do check out team human
definitely one of the best books I've
read I love this book so much and also
go and challenge yourself to go do
things like come just do you have really
good social interactions with with each
other find the others find the others to
do this with because this is the best
way for us to spiritually socially
evolve and as we face that exponential
technology era what are we getting how
are we gonna best mmm prosper moving
forward that's the bottom up then the
top down is also really important so
talk to your leaders and get some change
happening thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you we would love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below about some of the things that we
talked about really really start
pressing these conversations around more
check out Douglass's links below in the
bio and keep supporting artists and
entrepreneurs this is so so important
support people like Douglas like
simulations so we can keep the lights on
and keep growing support artisan
entrepreneurs everyone much love thanks
for tuning in and we will see you soon
build the future
[Music]